Hello there! Perhaps your
academic social media exploded too
or maybe you are still unaware
of the news, but it is true!
A pure Transformer beats the state-of-the art in
image recognition! Yes, you heard right! Images,
vision, the realm dominated for centuries by the
Convolutional Neural Networks, or short CNNs.
In this video we will explain how
the Transformer was able to beat
the CNN on its own image battleground
and we will discuss whether the rise
of the Transformer will really
mean the extinction of CNNs.
So it happened. The Transformers, which we
explained in a previous video, linked below,
took over the field of natural language
processing during the last couple of years.
It recently moved on to integrate vision and
language in Multimodal Transformer architectures
(find the explanation linked below).
Now, after some CNN-Transformer
hybrid attempts it happened:
The pure Vision Transformer is
the new state of the art, and this ruins
the CNN fascination of Ms. Coffee Bean!
Or... oh really?
But how does the transformer do it?
Well, by doing it better than CNNs for a start...!
A convolutional neural network uses kernels
to aggregate very local information
in each layer, which then is passed
to the next layer that aggregates again
local information, but now with a larger
field of view because it looks at information
that was already aggregated by the first layer.
The take home message here is that CNNs
start to look very locally and their
receptive field becomes more global in each
layer and after quite some training time.
But the Vision Transformer presented in this VERY
anonymous paper succeeds at having a large field
of view from the very beginning. It overcomes
the limitations of CNNs that look very narrowly
at first (limitations which helps when there's
not much training data, but about that later).
The Transformer looks at the image by
taking the input image and splitting
it into patches of 16 by 16 pixels.
These patches are then flattened by a
linear transformation, a matrix,
so that they become vectors.
Then, everything else what happens we know
from the language Transformer, because
the same thing is applied here: The vector of
each patch gets positional embeddings and a
usual Transformer is then used to predict what the
image might represent. Done. This was the method.
Why does it do better than CNNs? Because the
"anonymous" authors can train on an awful lot
of training data for an awful lot of TPU days.
That's something all anonymous authors can do.
Or not.
The Transformer is (unlike the CNN) very
data-hungry, especially because it has the freedom
to look everywhere onto the image from the start.
In other words, it is very unfocused
at first and it needs huge data
amounts to learn how to focus and what to focus
its attention on to make right predictions.
On many amounts of data, the Transformer can
find very original and unexpected ways to look
at the data, because there is
no element in the architecture
that tells the model how to do that exactly.
The CNN however, is focused from the beginning
by the convolutions towards a local view.
The given focus patterns can be a limitation,
but we can also spare a lot of training data
on this, because we do not have to teach the
model how to focus, only what to focus.
So will Transformers replace CNNs?
For heavyweight state-of-the art winners,
benchmark crushing, GPU intensive, data-hungry,
energy consuming, environmental unfriendly
kind of AI, yes, most probably, yeah possibly.
For lightweight Machine Learning in production,
for computational and energy economic settings,
for Green AI…. CNNs and even
far more classical approaches
will still be out there, at least for a while.
The paper discussed here is at ICLR still under
double-blind review. We will update the video
description with the full paper information, after
the authors have been revealed. Until then, try
to figure out yourself who the authors might be!
But do not tell the paper’s reviewers, otherwise
you might ruin the double-blind peer review!
Or was the whole setting ruined already?
Ok, bye!